hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
patient blood management the top four
things hospitals
should implement now i am jennifer woods
of labruz
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
presented by
lab route and brought to you by
radiometer to learn more
visit radiometer.com we encourage you to
participate
today by submitting any questions you
may have during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
yulia lin
division head transfusion medicine and
tissue bank
sunnybrook health sciences center dr
lynn
you may now begin your presentation
thanks so much to lab roots and
radiometer for inviting me to
participate in this webinar
i'm really excited to be here to talk
about patient blood management
and i really thought i'd focus the talk
on the top four things
that i think hospitals should be
implementing now
i have no conflicts of interest to
disclose
and so the objectives really for this
talk are to focus on
four top items so one to diagnose and
treat iron deficiency anemia
early two to incorporate
tranexamic acid into your patient blood
management toolbox
three apply strategies to minimize blood
work
and four prioritize using blood wisely
so just as a general introduction i
think it's really important just to
think about what
patient blood management is and this
is one definition there are several that
are out there but it's the
evidence-based multi-disciplinary
approach to optimizing care of patients
who might need
transfusions and so we often talk about
three pillars so the first is treating
anemia
the second minimizing blood loss and the
third
appropriate use of blood so you can see
how our objectives tie in to these three
pillars
and when we think about different
patients going through their
journey or their pathway we can think
about the operative patient
so preoperatively we think about
treating anemia
making sure we minimize blood loss both
pre-operatively
and during surgery and then
post-operatively
really thinking about how to ensure we
use appropriate
or used blood appropriately we can also
apply this to
the pregnancy setting so
you know in antenatal we really want to
optimize anemia treatment
look at minimizing blood loss during the
period delivery state
and then postpartum looking at the
appropriate use of blood
so let's move on to our first item so
that is
diagnose and treat iron deficiency
anemia early
so the most important thing here is that
iron deficiency
anemia is so common so even though it
might only be present in about one to
two percent of men
it's present in about five percent of
women in north america
and that can go up to 11 in teenagers
and then up to 30 percent in the third
trimester of pregnancy
it's not only in women but even when we
look at pre-operative anemia
and we look at multiple different types
of surgery
so whether it's prostate or orthopedic
or cardiac surgery anemia is present in
about a
third of patients so here you can see
that
the gray and the white bars represent
anemia abortioning
severity and so that might be present up
to
50 to 60 percent of patients that are
coming for gynecologic surgery
we also know looking at these patients
that
um a third of them or sorry a half of
them may also have iron deficiency
and so uh as being the cause of their
underlying anemia
and so it's a super common and something
that we really need to
think about and the reason why is that
anemia has important consequences
so we know that as the hemoglobin drops
below a 130 that there is an increased
risk
of blood transfusion and that holds for
major surgeries like orthopedic and
cardiac surgery
we also know that preoperative anemia is
associated with increased mortality
so whether it's from large databases for
example
in 2011 the u.s national surgical
quality improvement plan program
here with over 200 000
patients with administrative databases
they found an increased risk of
mortality
as well from systematic reviews the
latest from 2018 from the patient blood
management consensus conference
we also saw an increase in mortality
with an odds ratio of 2.09
associated with preoperative anemia
so how do we go about diagnosing and
treating iron deficiency anemia
so the first is what is anemia these are
who definitions
for males a hemoglobin less than 130
grams per liter or
13 grams per deciliter and for female
team of women less than 120 grams per
liter or 12 grams per deciliter
and i just want to bring up the one
point that in the setting of
preoperative
uh major blood loss surgery we
do think about the fact that certain
populations like females
or low body weight
you know with other comorbidities do
have lower hemoglobins and that even in
those patients we should be thinking
about
using a similar hemoglobin target of 130
and that's because they do you lose just
as much blood
um they do also note that in
large studies we see that there is a
decrease
in terms of outcomes or worsening of the
outcomes as the hemoglobin drops below
130. so
in this particular setting we often
think that we should be using similar
hemoglobin targets whether the patient
is male or female
in terms of iron deficiency that becomes
a little bit harder
we have clear definitions for absolute
iron deficiency
most commonly a ferritin less than 30 or
a ferritin less than 100 with a transfer
and saturation less than 20
um but if you look at different
guidelines that are out there whether
it's a gastroenterology association you
can see they use
slightly higher ferritin in the
congestive heart failure population
there have been trials that have looked
at
patients with iron deficiency as defined
here by a ferritin
less than 100 or less than 300
micrograms per liter with a transparent
saturation less than 20
and they have shown um that replacing
these patients with iron actually
improves outcomes
and so you know the definition of iron
deficiency anemia is not as
absolute um as we would like it to be
and so there may again be
different uh definitions that are used
depending on the patient's uh
underlying conditions
i'm not going to spend too much time
talking about the specifics of managing
iron deficiency anemia i think the most
important thing is to remember
that we must always think about what the
cause is of
iron deficiency anemia often this is a
bleeding cause
and so we need to be thinking about it
whether there's a occult
uh gastroenter intestinal cause source
for bleeding
um you know are there other issues that
we don't recognize and so we can't
forget that and jump to the second part
of managing which is really about iron
supplementation
and again i won't spend too much time
talking about the details of oral
and intravenous iron which are our two
mainstays and intravenous iron
typically for patients who don't
tolerate oral iron
what i do want to spend time on is just
looking for those
opportunities within your organization
of how we recognize
and diagnose iron deficiency early
so we can actually treat these patients
so
for sure a big part of what i do is
lead the blood conservation clinic here
and so we're always thinking about
pre-operative anemia and making sure
that we are
recognizing these patients early
especially those patients that are
undergoing
high blood loss surgery like ortho
cardiac and cancer
surgeries but also those that may be at
high risk for severe anemia
so those that often present with
bleeding colorectal
procedures or gynecologic procedures and
we try to make sure we can identify
these patients
four to eight weeks before surgery at
the first visit
of any type of visit where a patient
might have anemia as well
is a great time to also be screening so
this would be you know the first visit
for
a pregnant patient or the first visit of
a patient with a cancer diagnosis or the
first visit when a patient has heart
failure
and i'm going to show you some examples
too that even in the emergency
we can detect some of these patients and
offer treatment
so many patient blood management
organizations have
algorithms and many that are um
that are published out there this is one
from
the ontrax coordinator so the ontario
transfusion
coordinators which is a provincial
patient blood management
and and really it's sort of setting some
algorithms to help you
navigate and think about how we can sort
of expedite diagnosis and treatment
for patients that have anemia in those
settings so this is a pre-operative
algorithm
and really i can't stress enough how
important it is to detect anemia early
so this is probably the biggest
challenge if you can
get this going everything else seems to
fall in place so if we can coordinate
an early cbc to be done whether
um and this is just a few examples of
what we've done locally so
for orthopedics even before they see the
surgeon
often they see a physiotherapist or a
nurse to assess them
at that point we've tried to send out
letters to the primary care physician
to do a cbc and a fair agent early on
maybe they can be treated early with
oral iron and not even need intravenous
iron but the time to get to the
operation
gi oncology patients are referred to a
diagnostic assessment pathway nurse
and so again they're assessed before
they even see the surgeon and we are
arranging to have referrals sent to us
for any patients who have
iron deficiency anemia and same thing
with cardiac surgery so
at the time of the initial surgery
consultation we're having the surgeon
send us a cbc and a ferritin on these
patients
so that we can follow up for these
patients so
really important to figure out
ways to detect anemia early
just wanted to show a couple of um
slides here on just some of the quality
improvement
projects that have been conducted that
have been quite successful
so this is the opera quality improvement
project
optimizing pre-op anemia and these are
preliminary results from our gyne
oncology group here
they did a baseline
audit to see that 32 percent of the
patients had
anemia we introduced
systematic anemia screening um in the
clinic
so patients weren't regularly having a
cvc done so that went from
one percent up to 85 we referred these
patients to
uh the blood conservation clinic on a
more routine basis so that went up from
9
to 65 we were then able to treat anemia
in these patients from 7
to 33 and these were early results so
we're
running a little bit higher at this
point and then
as a result the perioperative
transfusion rates were
decreased from 20 to 12 so just sort of
an example of
the types of things that can be done in
a stepwise approach
the other interesting quality
improvement project that we've done is
looking at
how to optimize iron deficiency anemia
management in the emergency department
so here's just an algorithm that really
focuses first
on recognition and some parameters of
how to diagnose iron deficiency anemia
and then if you follow it through you
can see if patients
at the bottom are asymptomatic we really
encourage the use of
iv iron or oral iron in those cases
and only when their hemoglobin's quite
low considering transfusion
and if they're symptomatic then for sure
considering transfusion but then also
remembering to treat the underlying
cause in terms of the iron deficiency
and of course referral for gi
or guiding investigations depending on
what the underlying cause might be
and so with this algorithm we were able
to show with
multiple steps within our quality
improvement project
by having intravenous iron in the
emergency department
introducing guidelines getting some
stakeholder feedback
presenting to grand rounds for the
emergency department
um having access to a transfusion
physician for advice
and then we also had some educational
tools in terms of a podcast
as well as an iron deficiency anemia
toolkit that we were able to improve the
appropriateness of transfusion for iron
deficiency anemia
that was sustained over the next
following year
so just a couple of ideas of of how we
can implement
approaches to managing diagnosing and
managing iron deficiency anemia
okay so moving on to the second topic so
here
i want to talk a little bit about
incorporating
tranexamic acid into the patient-managed
blood management toolbox so tranexamic
acid
is an anti-fibrinolytic so
it inhibits the binding of placentagen
to fibrin and therefore prevents the
degradation of fibrin products
and so um tranexamic acid has been
studied
quite a bit so this is a systematic
review and this is from
2012 but already at that point there's
been 129
rcts some of them smaller in size but
definitely showed a decrease in
transfusion
and this was across many different
surgical
settings particularly in cardiac and
orthopedic surgery
but as you can see many other types of
surgery as well
and having a pretty consistent effect in
terms of decreasing
the need for transfusion
this is just a graph of looking at a
figure that looks at
the role of tranexamic acid in the
setting of
acute trauma so what it shows here
in the first couple of bars so in dark
gray are the patients that were treated
with tranexamic acid
and on the y-axis it's patients that
were hypo coagulopathic so
you can translate that into not forming
cot
and then in light gray were those who
were not treated for trending famic acid
and you can see from the emergency
department to the icu
there was a decrease in that
hypokaliculopathy in terms of the
percentage of patients with that
compared to not being treated with
tranexamic acid where it actually got
worse
and same thing when they looked at
patients who were massively transfused
they saw that similar pattern that there
was a dramatic decrease in terms of that
hypocoagulopathy
once patients were treated with
tranexamic acids
and so um that's really you know
translated into
this or has been fully i guess further
supported
by the crash 2 study so this is
the big study looking at trauma patients
20 000 patients
um who presented um hemodynamically
unstable
they were randomized to tranexamic acid
one gram
with a one gram infusion over eight
hours versus placebo
and you can see here that there was a
decrease in mortality
of 1.5 percent a decrease in
deaths due to bleeding although no inc
decrease in transfusion
and no increase in vascular occlusive
events for example stroke or
thromboembolic events
the important thing to remember about
tranexamic acid is that you need to give
it
early so as you can see here
on the x-axis that is treatment delay
from zero to 180 minutes
um and the effectiveness decreases
to about zero at about 180 minutes so
really important to give the treatment
without delay
and typically in the first three hours
after three hours it likely does not
have a benefit
at that point in terms of um
other areas the woman trial looked at
peripartum delivery and specifically
patients with postpartum hemorrhage
again really large studies 20 000
patients who were randomized to
tranexamic acid one gram
and then a second gram if there was
ongoing bleeding in the next 24 hours
versus placebo
and again no difference in terms of the
primary cause of death from all causes
but death due to bleeding within 42 days
there was a decrease
especially if given within the first
three hours
um as you can see on the next slide
that's the breakdown of um in the top
there
that circle from time from delivery less
than one hour or one to three hours
that is when there was a survival
advantage in terms of the death from
bleeding
on that favored trending tranexamic acid
there are instances where tranexamic
acid
may not be effective and so this is a
most recent trial
published called the halted trial and
this looked at patients who had
either upper or lower gi bleeding and
they were randomized to tranexamic acid
one gram load with a three gram
fusion over 24 hours versus placebo
and you can see here that actually there
was no difference in terms of death due
to bleeding
um there was no difference in terms of
arterial robotic events
but a slight increase in terms of
venous thrombotic events which occurred
in the tranexamic acid group
and this was particularly in those
patients that had
varicial bleed or liver disease and so
this is
likely the one major area
where we have stepped away from using
tranexamic acid routinely
are those patients with gi bleeds as it
has not shown any benefit
and potential flag of harm
so just to summarize when to think about
using tranexamic acid
if you're going to use it use it early
to start within three hours from onset
of bleeding in the trauma cases
orthopedic spine cardiac surgery and
obstetrical hemorrhage
we have incorporated that into our
massive hemorrhage protocol
in terms of dose there's a variety of
doses although often
practically speaking the tranexamic acid
2 gram ib bolus
is likely most practical in terms of
remembering to give the second dose
and uh in general there has not been an
increase in thromboembolic events in the
rcts
except for the halted trial and note
that these patients
generally patients that had a history of
thrombosis weren't included in the
clinical trials
[Music]
a couple of things to be aware of in
terms of contraindications
so typically we do avoid the use of
tranexamic acid if we
know there's a history or risk of
thrombosis or
an acute thrombotic event some patients
can
acquire some disturbances of color
vision although that is typically with
long-term use generally it's
contraindications
indicated in patients with hematuria
although i'll note that
in the trauma style the crash study the
crash 2 study
there wasn't a specific um exclusion for
this
criteria and
the there's also caution in patients
with
um disseminated intravascular velocity
in terms of side effects it's generally
well tolerated
patients can have some gi side effects
again impaired color vision with
long-term use
and the concept of seizures which is
most often described in the cardiac
surgery setting
okay so we'll move to the third topic
area which is
apply strategies to minimize blood work
so i think this isn't maybe one of the
more
exciting areas but i think it's actually
a very practical um
uh topic and i think really important
maybe something that's
overlooked um quite often and so if we
think about
how much blood is actually drawn um
daily
blood draws in the icu have been
quantitated at about
40 mils per day um and
in a study looking at icu versus general
medicine
you know icu patients were getting three
draws per day compared to once per day
for general medicine
those volumes were about 40 compared to
12 mils per day for general medicine
and the mean total volume of phlebotomy
and one of the studies was 762 ml
of blood that is drawn um versus 175 ml
so that's more than two red cell units
in terms of volume
um in terms of phlebotomy volume
and blood loss so these can really
impact
a patient's stay and so
there have been more recent studies that
have looked at how this
can impact in the general internal
medicine
group patients looking at
mean volumes that they had during their
stay maybe a little bit less in terms of
75 mils
but the volume that they had was
independently associated with the
hemoglobin drop
so they noted for every 100 ml of blood
draw
drawn there was a hemoglobin drop of 0.7
grams per deciliter
so it's not um it's
you know quite impressive that the tests
that we order can result in these
hemoglobin drops in the icu this is a
recent study
from mcmaster looking at the median
blood volume for lab testing for icu
patients which is
around 213 ml and again the cumulative
blood
loss due to the labs was independently
associated with red cell transfusion
so i had a ratio of 2.3 for each 150 ml
of blood drawn so it can have a really
important impact
and so many have recognized uh this
as being important so choosing wisely
we have the critical care society is
collaborative of critical care
made up of these organizations their
first
recommendation is don't order diagnostic
tests at regular intervals
such as every day but rather do it in
response to specific clinical questions
and so this applies not only to blood
but also to chest x-rays
so it's just really important to get
away from that routine
you know every six hours or every daily
blood work
when we don't need it and so
in terms of interventions um there are
many
um organizations again societies on the
right here in the table
that have listed uh specific um
recommendations around uh unnecessary
testing but really trying to minimize
unnecessary testing and that can be done
a number of ways so one is you know
review the order set
so i think looking at order sets often
order sets
may have you know blood work daily
for a number of days maybe we need to
review that
and make sure that they're not ordered
or maybe there are tests that are
ordered that are
totally unnecessary you know removing
those from the order sets completely
thinking about restricting accessibility
of certain tests so
in canada for example
rbc folate is rarely
or folate deficiency is rarely an issue
and so
you know we have really restricted the
access of that for example at our
institution
you need to actually call the biochemist
if you want to get an rbc
folate so there's certain tests that we
could restrict access to
and then the last is just reassess the
frequency of testing
so build in systems that will note that
you know the same blood work was done
yesterday so sometimes you'll see that
patients have had
you know repeated for example hemoglobin
a1cs
that really should not be done more
often than every three months for
example
so just trying to work in systems
into our automated systems to try to
recognize
and you know cancel some of these uh
frequently ordered tests
or sorry the frequency of tests that may
not be indicated
um this was a systematic review looking
at actually reducing the
volume of testing so just looking at how
much
is drawn per blood drop
and so this looked at or identified aid
studies
so there were three studies that look at
looked at blood collection tube
intervention
so using blood test tubes that require
just smaller volumes
and then five studies that looked at
different arterial line
setups that helped to either avoid
drawing you know the initial blood draw
that
um might be diluted for example or
returning any of that
um blood back to the patient instead of
discarding it
and you can see here that all the
studies show that they were able to
reduce
the volume of the blood draw from 19 to
up to 80 percent
with these different techniques so i
just wanted to tell you about
one interesting study that's being led
out of
mcmaster which looked at
as called the strata study and what they
did was they looked at
implementing these soft draw tubes so
they're small volume tubes
with the goal to reduce anemia and
transfusion and it was a pilot study but
i think it's been um
converted to a multi-center
study and um what they have here are
these soft draw vacutainer tubes and
there's you know pictured on the left
they're the same cost
they're the same size in terms of um
fitting into the instrumentation but
they have a lower volume
um two to three mills compared to four
to ten mils so they have about
20 to 25 percent less vacuum so they
don't pull in as much blood
um into the tube and they were able to
show that they reduced the blood loss
from 11 ml to 6 ml per day
there was an overall 45 reduction in
blood loss
and they didn't find any barriers to
implementation in terms of
amongst the nurses or the lab staff so
there was a lot of
satisfaction with this process and so
i think this is something that can be
looked at and probably should be looked
at at your institution in terms of what
types
of tubes you're using for your
laboratory testing
okay we're going to move to the final
topic which is
prioritize using blood wisely
so there have been
many studies again that have looked at
restrictive
versus liberal transfusion and
have not shown any difference in terms
of outcomes with respect to
mortality and this is a slide
from one of my colleagues that
summarized some of the
observational studies that have been
done these are all surgical studies
where they looked at patients undergoing
the specific types of surgeries
and compared those patients who were
transfused versus those patients who did
not receive a transfusion
and looked at their 30-day mortality and
you can see across the board
there was increased mortality associated
with transfusion
and so over time we have recognized that
it's
really important to think about
restrictive transfusion
so that we are providing
appropriate care to our patients so when
possible
transfusing don't transfuse more than
one unit at a time
in a non-bleeding hemodynamically stable
patient
and then the other is really looking at
transfusion threshold so don't transfuse
red cells
in asymptomatic non-bleeding patients
with a hemoglobin greater than
70 or a higher threshold for patients
with active cardiovascular disease
and so there are actually you know over
eight to ten
societies again that have also included
these in their choosing wisely
statements
in terms of restrictive transfusion
so again you know what are the
interventions that we can put into place
um to think a little bit about how we
improve practice um so this was a
recent review of 84 studies looking at
behavioral interventions to reduce red
cell transfusion
and you can see on the right there were
things like education guidelines and
reminders
which unfortunately alone did not cause
any great
change in terms of uh reducing
transfusion
but only when you had um in addition to
that
either adding decision support to
um for example computer provider order
entry
or prospective screening and audit or
different types of policy interventions
or the greatest decrease which was
combining all of these
components or different various
components that's when you saw that
there was actually an improvement
in red cell transfusion so i wanted to
tell you a little bit about some of the
things that we've done
locally unfortunately not all systems
can
incorporate clinical decision support
systems or have
electronic patient records i think we're
all moving in that direction and so i
think for sure
i'm building those order processes
in to help guide the clinician in terms
of
ordering transfusion is important but
what we've done here
is a little bit more in terms of
empowering the medical labor
technologists
within the lab to sort of help with
the oversight and ensuring that
transfusion's used appropriately
so this was one of our initial studies
looking at
improving transfusion at a single site
we partnered with them um in 2013
uh with our local site sunnybrook and
university health network um education
on the guidelines was
introduced and then we introduced um
perspective order screening where
the medical laboratory technologists
would actually screen each of the orders
and determine whether or not they were
um outside of guidelines
if they were outside of guidelines then
that would be escalated to the
transfusion physician
on call to help have a discussion with
the ordering physician
and so the medical advisory council
approved this process which was really
important to help set the stage for
um how the transfusion culture and how
blood should be transfused at lake ridge
and then over time we went to 24
7 screening across the
the week days and weekends and you can
see with that that
um the number of red cells transfused
over time
decreased by a third so much so that we
needed to
adjust the inventory and there was uh
in terms of a balancing measure we used
a hospital death which didn't change
over the time of implementation of
this program
and so this has also been rolled out on
a
larger scale with the start study so
this was
looking at screening by technologists to
reduce
transfusion and so again use the very
similar type of intervention
which was multimodal and that was
ensuring that guidelines were in place
and this was
13 participating hospitals across canada
um there were education sessions that
were provided
not only for the physicians but also for
the technologists in terms of how to
screen orders
there was prospective screening by the
laboratory technologists with approval
before issue of anything any orders that
were suspected to be
not adherent to the guidelines and then
monthly auditing of appropriateness with
feedback to the clinical team
and so with that during this
time period which was 10 months after
the intervention
uh there were 1950 patients that were
audited
with over 2 800 red cells transfused
and the appropriateness of the
transfusions
increased from 73.5 to 85
there was a decrease in the
pre-transfusion hemoglobin
an increase in the single unit
transfusions
across the hospitals and a significant
decrease in the number of red cells
transfused so over these 13 hospitals
there was a decrease of 500 units per
month
and when we looked at a balancing
measure of under transfusion
it was actually pretty low so only about
2.2 percent
of the under transfusion events so those
were events that didn't get a
transfusion even though the hemoglobin
was less than 60
which was not explained by lab era or
clear medical
religious reasons it was pretty unusual
for that to occur and the intervention
did not change the length of stay or the
need for icu support or in hospital
mortality
again in terms of balancing measures
so you know we've brought that into
using blood wisely so
the um last issue in terms or the last
topic
i really wanted to tell you a little bit
about using blood wisely which is
choosing wisely canada's first national
implementation campaign and we've done
that with our national blood supplier
canadian blood services
and the campaign challenges hospitals to
benchmark themselves
on appropriate transfusion practices and
to lead by example through the adoption
of a defined set of
evidence-informed and proven strategies
and so really the aim is to decrease
inappropriate red cell transfusions in
canada
and so i just wanted to show you just a
few screenshots from it but
really we started in september of 2020
and it was just sort of take the
challenge you know do an audit are your
hospitals using blood wisely
um hospitals would do an audit we made
it pretty simple
some hospitals had automated processes
for this some hospitals did it manually
but we
just asked hospitals to do a transfusion
report for about 50 consecutive
inpatients
to identify 50 transfusion episodes and
really looked at inpatient since
our guidelines really apply to
inpatients as opposed to outpatients
um the hospitals looked at their
benchmarks and these ventures were set
as 65
of the red cell transfusion episodes are
single unit
and at least 80 percent of the
transfusions had a pre-transfusion
hemoglobin of 80 or less
so again just accounting for the fact
that there may be bleeding patients who
need
double units triple units or you have
some patients
who who are bleeding or have cardiac
disease and might need higher hemoglobin
thresholds
so um really setting these benchmarks
and then
if they weren't met then really
enrolling in a equality improvement
initiative
to sort of help the hospital move
forward with these
and if they were met then hospitals
received a using blood wisely hospital
designation
and so we designed an intervention
toolbox which had
templates for guidelines and education
and order sets
also some information on prospective
screening
and alternatives to blood and supported
hospitals through this process
with a series of practice webinars to
walk them through these different stages
from the spot audit to planning setting
up their
for success and then actually doing the
intervention and measuring
so i'm really excited to say that since
we started in september we have 192
participating hospitals um as of
june 21st so this is a a little month
behind our
target was to get 200 hospitals signed
up
um we have 58 hospitals that have
achieved their designation of using
blood wisely so they've
met the targets that we've set and as
well as sustain them
and um you know these 192 hospitals um
that are participating at various stages
account for about two-thirds of the red
cells that are transfused in canada
so um you know it's not just small
hospitals that are participating but we
have really
um a wide breadth of hospitals that are
participating
in the uh initiative and so just showing
some
baseline audit data but just you know
percent single unit transfusions on the
x-axis and on the y-axis the percent of
transfusions with
a pre-transfusion hemoglobin of less
than 80. and our goal is to get all
these dots
into the top right corner so just gives
you an idea that there are some that are
already there but there are some that
need some help pushing up towards that
top right corner
so you know what is the value of of
everything that i've talked about today
um you know we've talked about the
sort of different interventions and each
of the pillars for patient blood
management
and and our hope is that the value is to
kind of hopefully emulate some of the
things that have been done
in other countries so this is a study
from western australia that looked at
their
patient blood management programs over
the years
and and they instituted this starting in
2008-2009
so you can see there was a pretty
significant decrease
in terms of the number of red cell units
transfused even though in gray in the
background
is the increase the slow increase in the
population
in that region and so with this um
the the value was shown that they were
able to show over the years
some associations with decreased
in hospital mortality and length of stay
decrease in hospital acquired infections
no increase in acute myocardial
infarction or stroke if anything
decreased although they did have a
slight increase in 28 day readmissions
but the idea is that hopefully with
these patient blood management
programs that encompass many items and
sorry i forgot to say that in
western australia they had you know
multimodal
interventions from appropriate
transfusions to managing iron deficiency
um to minimizing blood loss and surgery
so it was really
all across the board a real complete
patient blood management program that
with these patient blood management
programs we will improve
care so in summary um
i hope i've given you you know something
to think about
in terms of these four topic areas
hopefully some ideas of things that you
might be able to take home
and you know think about how you might
incorporate them
into your hospitals and your
organizations
um and i think you know the whole goal
of this is really to
improve outcomes for our patients so
with that
thank you very much uh really excited to
be here and i'd be
happy to take any questions at this
point
thank you dr lynn for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
is there any value to reticulocyte
hemoglobin
in managing iron deficiency anemia
patients
thanks for the question i hope you guys
can hear me well
um so i think uh there are a number of
uh alternative markers that are out
there in terms of evaluating iron
deficiency anemia
i think the tricky part of it is that
they're not usually available
at all hospitals they're often available
depending
on the type of analyzer that you have
for
the cbc and so measures like
reticulated hemoglobin content
have been studied and low levels
for example less than 29 picograms have
been
used to predict response to iv iron
or to indicate iron deficiency rather
than anemia of inflammation
so there's definitely a role but i think
there's just a bit less experience
with those biomarkers but if you do have
them at your institution i think
they may be something of added value
that you could use
um locally so so i think it uh
again just less experience i think and
sort of less publications on them than
the usual
sort of ferritin and iron studies that
were
usually sort of more universally and
widely available but definitely
a potential role locally
thank you dr lynn the next question is
is there any specific rationale for
using tranexamic acid versus anakar
yeah so um i guess you know we always
present from our local jurisdictions
and um locally i guess maybe
it's almost 10 years ago we had a large
study
called the bart study that looked at
cardiac surgery and tranexamic acid
immunocoproic acid
um and you know there were some issues
in terms of amino caproic acid and that
group not doing as well
um and so for a temporary
uh period of time aminocortic acid was
withdrawn from the market here in canada
i think was still available in the us
and it did get sort of brought back onto
the market but
i think at least in the canadian context
we never really never got back
to using immunocoproic acid as you can
see most of the data that i've presented
um even though a medical process it has
a similar mechanism of action
most of the studies have looked at
tranexamic acid
and so i think that that is why we tend
to use [ __ ] stomach acid
um but i again i think it sort of
depends on your local experiences there
may be cost issues
and um you know i think there are uh
likely benefits i think the main goal is
to think about using etsy for analytics
when you can
in most of these cases
all right thanks again dr lynn our next
question is
do you recommend that patients take oral
iron supplements on alternative days
oh so that's a great question so um
there have been some studies that have
come out that have looked at taking
daily versus every other day and
a couple of the earlier studies
suggested that if you took it every
other day
you would have a greater fractional
absorption so you would absorb
more of the oral iron than you would if
you took it
every day however when you looked at the
differences
in hemoglobin for example
there wasn't really big changes in terms
of that effect so
the thought is that if you take it every
other day perhaps you might have fewer
side effects
and still get a pretty good absorption
of the iron
so you know in practice i don't think we
know what we're
we we should do um for all patients
uh we're running a a small randomized uh
pilot trial here looking at daily versus
every other day
right now in practice uh what i
recommend is to
give it daily and if they can't tolerate
it to take it every other day
and then go from there in terms of
minimizing side effects so
great question but i don't think we need
to change practice quite yet
okay great thanks again dr lynn our next
question is
is there an initiative or interventions
ongoing to use one tube
for two or more tests to decrease the
amount of blood drawn
yeah that's a great question i'm i'm not
aware of
of specific published accounts for that
but i think that these are
really the basis for some of the quality
improvement
uh initiatives that could be taken out
at individual centers
you know are there ways that we can use
um
a tube a single tube for different tests
and
a lot of that has to do with um
automated
uh lines for uh chemistry testing
and just sort of those process issues so
i mean i think those are definitely i
think that's definitely one initiative
to think about
you know unfortunately different tubes
do require different tubes or sorry
different tests do require different
tube types so sometimes it's not
entirely
possible but i think that that would be
something to look at within your
processes at your institution
thank you again dr lynn our next
question is
do your technologist prospectively audit
or blood orders
yeah so again the devil's always in the
details so
um so at our institution we do not
prospectively audit
or blood orders or you know bleeding
unstable patients so we try to get that
blood out as soon as possible
sometimes if there's something that
doesn't quite uh make sense you know
often
we get orders not just for red cells but
let's say for plasma and it's a one unit
order for plasma or
two unit order for plasma um you know
we'll start to get it ready
and we'll just do a quick call um
into the or and just sort of see if we
can help out with those situations
in fact i think one of our fellows just
had a call for this exact um
question this morning so you know i
think
we don't try to limit you know obviously
those are very dynamic situations
sometimes we don't have
access to the most recent blood values
because they're using of point-of-care
testing for example
so we're always a little bit more
cautious in those bad dynamic situations
all right thank you again dr lynn our
next question is
what are the retrospective data reviews
done to see the effective
effectiveness of your pvm program at
your institution
yeah so um so there's i guess a few ways
that could be
done so one you can look at
uh total blood use for example um
you can look at um
the number of red cells that have been
used adjusted for the inpatient activity
as i've shown
and then you can always important not
only to look at
um and we've done actually chart audits
as well for sort of
retrospective um appropriateness scores
and those are
a bit more labor intensive because you
have to go into the chart and really
kind of make a judgment call in terms of
whether you think they're appropriate or
not
so i think those are sort of some of the
examples we've used things like single
unit
transfusions in hemodynamically stable
patients
and pre-transfusion hemoglobin
thresholds as surrogate markers for of
course
appropriateness always important to
remember about
balancing measures you know so you know
are there patients who are getting under
transfused and
as i presented in the start study this
is a pretty rare phenomenon but
important to look at
and in some of our uh as well as in the
start study we did look at sort of
global measures in terms of things like
icu
um like the stay and complications from
what you might think would be under
transfusion
just to make sure that we weren't seeing
any other uh problems as a result of the
restrictive transfusion threshold and we
were not able to identify those so yeah
great question i think you're thinking
about something that
you can look at and a lot of the time it
looks at it depends on feasibility of
what you can measure
and collect as well as thinking about
balancing measures
all right thank you dr lynn the next
question is
is there any alternative method to
reduce blood transfusions in thalassemia
and sickle cell anemia patients
that's a great question
it's a bit out of my area of clinical
expertise is i don't
we don't have a large population of red
cell disorders at our institution
i mean i i think that in these cases we
are really thinking about new drug
therapies for these patients so
it's a pretty exciting time because
there are
uh new drug therapies that are becoming
available to help
mitigate um the
[Music]
number of crises that are occurring and
general well-being for patients with
sickle cell
in particular and so i think that those
are
therapies that we're going to see more
and more of so i think those are usually
outside
of the sort of direct laboratory and
transfusion aspects
um but like a really great point so i
think you really
need to work you know in all of these
you really need to work with your
clinical
uh teams just to see you know what are
those multimodal interventions that
don't always
only include lab or the transfusion
service
to see how you can best optimize blood
management for these patients
all right thank you dr lynn our next
question is
any recommendations for engaging
surgical services and other relevant
stakeholders in pbm
yeah so you know i think when initiating
on any of these types of
initiatives it's just important first to
realize that sometimes it does take a
lot of time
um and and just to go step by step so
uh with surgical services i think you
know one of the things would be to start
thinking
about you know first of all
pick one of the surgery areas surgical
areas you know doesn't have to be
all of the surgical procedures but pick
an area
and then you know see if there's you
know one surgeon that you can work with
um and and try to sort of
uh meet with them and start to think
about you know helping them with their
patience
and then start to be able to show that
you've had a
few cases where you've been successful
um
in in moving things forward or in
showing an improvement for example in
the management of anemia
so i think just you know taking things
step by step
um is a great approach especially when
you're starting off and then as you kind
of develop a little bit more experience
and gain a bit more traction then you
start to expand
you know i think especially in the
surgical areas the
pre-operative clinics and the
pre-operative nurses
are are wonderful and
um i guess as i mentioned in the first
part
of the talk you know really trying to
sort out where
you can first just make that initial
recognition that patients have anemia
is a really huge step and that might
even just be with the
admins for the secretary of the admins
in the offices of the surgeons
or in the pre-assessment clinic
thank you dr lynn our next question is
iv iron treatment for women with
menorrhagia is
challenging in certain demographical
parts of the city when it comes to cost
no insurance no trillium and it's
challenging
eap coverage would be great but
challenges exist do you have any
thoughts
yeah so i think this is a great question
i mean i i think that this is
something in healthcare that we all have
to deal with you know in canada we're
pretty lucky as we do have universal
care but we don't actually have
universal health drug
care so you know for patients that are
under the age of 65
we don't have great programs to help
fund
the cost of medications so you know we
have
um encouraged uh
enrollment in programs like trillium
which in
our jurisdiction um takes into account
uh how much you make in terms of your
finances and sort of assign the
deductible before
there is coverage of drugs um
you know locally we set up a patient
blood management fund
for patients who can't afford iv iron
and uprights we've had that
uh for about a year it's been really
successful and
you know we encourage those who can uh
or want to say thank you to sort of pay
it forward
to other patients who might not be able
to afford um
a drug so i think this is a a constant
um struggle you know i think
at the end of the day making business
cases as well that might be able to show
the benefits of patient blood management
um
can also help to justify the costs of
these uh pre-operative
anemia management interventions
it's challenging definitely challenging
um and
i think especially in a universal health
care system where we have a
limited finite number of resources that
can be
really hard so i think it's kind of a
couple of ideas i guess to help address
those
thank you dr lynn i have time for a few
more questions here
is there a target ferritin transfer and
saturation we should be aiming for
preoperatively
yeah great question um typically we use
the ferritin and the transfer and
saturation
really up front so we don't typically
measure it again and that's because if
we've given
intravenous iron um it's actually quite
challenging uh to measure what the true
ferritin and transparent saturation is
it takes usually
i find a few weeks for those numbers to
kind of equilibrate so i don't usually
recheck those beforehand in an
outpatient if they're getting iv iron i
will check it about one to two months
after
the intravenous iron to take a look at
so
that can be quite helpful
great our next question is what type of
response
should i expect after administration of
iv iron
what is the best way to follow the
efficacy of treatment
uh great so typically uh we would
expect you know we usually say about a
10
gram per liter or one gram per deciliter
increase
in the hemoglobin um per week
somewhere between 5 to 10 or 0.5 to 1
gram
deciliter are grams per deciliter for
hemoglobin
improvement again sometimes
patients do have other components like
anemia inflammation and so you may not
see
as grave response as you would expect
but typically we do follow with a
hemoglobin
and a rich account in those cases
[Music]
all right thank you again dr lynn
looks like that's all we have time for
today before we go do you have any final
comments for our audience
so i just wanted to say thanks very much
uh for having me inviting me to
uh this session and thanks to all the
audience for listening in and for all of
your questions
i hope you found it really helpful
well thank you again to our speaker dr
yulia lynn
for your time today and for your
important research we would also like to
thank labyrinth and our sponsor
radiometer for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye